foreign
thank you Brian
thank you conference it's a real
privilege to be here in Birmingham to
address you at such a pivotal moment for
our country
but the Vox
in the NEC
a place where so many greats of music
and theater have played
Bob Dylan
David Bowie Justin Bieber he's coming
here soon
and who could forget
in 2019
the all-time favorite of the CBI
Peppa Pig
yes
she played here too
but look I'm here today to talk about
Labor's plan for Britain how together we
can build a fairer Greener more Dynamic
country
a nation where working people succeed
where aspiration is rewarded a Britain
with its confidence its hope and its
future back
I come with a simple message
labor is ready
to give Britain the clear economic
leadership it needs ready to work with
you to drive our country forward
not just a pro-business party
but a party that is proud of being
pro-business that respects the
contribution profit makes to our jobs
growth and our tax base that gets that
working people want success as well as
support
understands that backing private
Enterprise is the only way Britain pays
its way in the world
and mark my words this is a matter of
conviction for me and I've United my
party behind it
anyone who came to our conference this
summer anyone I've met since being
leader more than 100 CEOs in the last
six months alone knows this already
this is a different labor party and
there's no going back we're ready for
partnership
and let's be frank
because we need to be
partnership is not a nice to have it's
now an economic imperative
I don't want to waste too much time
today talking about the government
but the economic damage they've done to
our country is immense
they've put our public finances in a
perilous position wasted the chance to
transform our potential in an era of low
interest rates
created an economy with weak foundations
this isn't about global shocks that's
just an excuse
nobody criticizes the government for not
anticipating the war in Ukraine
or denies the war was the spark for the
cost of living crisis
but the war didn't ban onshore wind the
war didn't scrap home insulation and the
war didn't stall British nuclear energy
and when it comes to economic growth the
verdict of the former Chancellor is
right
they've created a vicious cycle of
stagnation
and that's why every crisis hits Britain
harder than our competitors
the only country in the G7 still poorer
than it was before the pandemic
disposable income back to 2013 levels
the worst decade for growth in two
centuries
that's why we need a new partnership
economic growth is the oxygen for our
Ambitions the lifeblood of a strong
society and a dynamic economy
but we have to confront the reality of
our position
the lessons of the past 12 years can't
be ignored
just stop for a moment
and think what working people have been
through
they were told we're all in it together
then they paid for a mess made by Banks
they cried out for economic change in a
referendum
but saw their calls go unanswered
and they United to defeat a deadly virus
only to see the government break the
rules that they respected
and now a winter like no other
the biggest hit to living standards in
British history
where Millions the length and breadth of
our country will go without food or
Heating
once again
asked to pay the price
don't get me wrong I know people in this
room are struggling to
your borrowing rates through the roof
energy costs astronomical
more small businesses going under now
than at any time since records begun
and I know that every single one is a
personal tragedy an ambition a dream an
investment in a better future
gone
no mistake
it's tough
and it will be tough for a while
but that's why we need to answer the
burning question
what will we do differently
how will we help restore the contract
that says work hard and Britain will
give you a fair chance
because let me tell you that's not how
working people feel about our country
right now
not this winter
so this has to be a turning point
Britain needs a new business model
and that will be hard
changing a business model is hard you
all know that
nonetheless it's time for all of us
government business trade unions
to get behind the idea both basic and
radical
that our country can grow in a way that
serves working people
that higher productivity can come from
unlocking their potential and that we
can work together to put their interests
first
this has to be the common goal of our
partnership and it must set a new
Direction on growth a new way of
governing that at times is challenging
our instincts and will challenge our
instincts
no more trickle-down experiments that
idea has been tested to destruction
but equally
if the southeast races ahead
redistribution can't be the one word
plan for the rest of Britain
you can grow an economy that way of
course you can
but it's not enough
working people want growth from the
Grassroots
jobs that are well paid and secure
communities standing on their own feet
Public Services strong enough to help
them succeed
so I promise you now
my labor government will care must care
as much about raising productivity
everywhere as we've done in the past
about redistribution
we're going to throw everything at
growing our Collective contribution our
productive capacity in every community
and that takes us inevitably to the
supply side of the economy
that's why our first priority on tax
has always been to scrap business rates
we will level the playing field for our
high streets
and with help from Lord Jim O'Neill
we'll make Britain the best place in the
world to start a new business
but we also need to look at the supply
side differently
it's not just about tax and Enterprise
take the current state of our labor
market
so much of this comes back to our Public
Services
yes there are other factors
but you can't tell me that the number of
older people falling out of work has got
nothing to do with the millions stuck on
NHS waiting lists
or that the growing number of people
suffering with mental health isn't a
drag on our productivity
no
the state of our Public Services is an
economic crisis
just as much as a social crisis
so we will launch the biggest training
program since the creation of the NHS
increased capacity with more doctors
more nurses more Health visitors reform
the employment service to get more
people back to work
give everyone who needs it access to
mental health treatment within four
weeks and build a modern child care
system that supports parents especially
women to flourish
this is what the U.S treasury secretary
Janet Yellen calls modern supply side
economics
and that's the philosophy that will
drive us to do the hard yards on growth
but will also need to be pragmatic on
the basic lack of people
we won't ignore the need for workers to
come to this country
we can't have a situation as we did with
hgv drivers where temporary shortages
threatened to [ __ ] entire sectors of
our economy
that would be anti-growth
and it would be anti-business
but I want to be clear here
with my labor government
any movement in our points-based
migration system whether via the skilled
worker route
or the shortage occupations list
will come alongside new conditions for
business
we will expect you to bring forward a
clear plan to boost skills and more
training for better pay and condition
for investment in new technology now we
can talk about how this is done
dialogue is at the heart of partnership
but negotiation with trade unions will
be part of it
I said at the TUC conference
my labor party is unashamably
pro-business
and I say here today that trade unions
must be a crucial part of our
partnership
but our common goal must be to help the
British economy off its immigration
dependency
to start investing more in trading
workers who are already here
migration is part of our national story
always has been always will be
and the labor party will never diminish
the contribution it makes to our economy
to public services to your businesses
and our communities
but let me tell you
the days when low pay and cheap labor
are part of the British way on growth
must end
this isn't about brexit
all around the world businesses waking
up to the fact we live in a new era for
labor
and while they're adapting
our low growth model is holding us back
it's why we've set out a new deal for
working people that will deliver higher
pay stronger rights and better work
not just for social justice
but also for the new reality on growth
let me give you an example
technology
Britain has fewer industrial robots than
almost every comparable country
we're behind Germany France Spain
Slovenia Slovakia Belgium it's a long
list
and in terms of competition over the
long run
one that borders on disaster
now I know most businesses get this
I've seen for myself how you invest in
your people and their productivity
at valence in Derbyshire
I met the apprentices using their skills
in conjunction with the new technologies
of heat pumps
that technology will continue to adapt
but those apprentices will be at the
Forefront of that change
working today training for the
opportunities of the future
but when we look at the economy as a
whole
it can seem like we're more comfortable
hiring people to work in low pay
insecure sometimes exploitative
contracts than we are in investing in
the new technology that delivers for
workers productivity and our country
and we can't compete like that
Britain's low pay model has to go
it doesn't serve working people it's not
compatible with Grassroots growth
so let me tell you what is
the three big priorities for my labor
government
the principles our partnership must
deliver to drive Britain forward
they are one
economic stability
two higher skills
three green growth
and we take them one by one starting
with economic stability
because as you know
stability is the Bedrock
everything else depends on it
if we've learned nothing else these past
12 years
it's that chaos has a cost
that's why every policy under my labor
party announced will always be fully
costed
we're determined to reduce debt as a
share of our economy
sound money in our public finances must
come first
and we accept what this means
except that we won't be able to do
things good labor things
as quickly as we would like
the lesson of the last few months is
Stark
lose control of the economy and its
businesses and working people who pick
up the bill
and I won't let that happen again
but real economic stability has to be
about more than public finances
it has to be about providing the right
conditions to plan and invest to think
about long-term strategy not just
short-term fixes
to create confidence through certainty
that's the argument for partnership
it's why we're so committed to a modern
industrial strategy
it's not about the size of the state
it's about what the state does
how it supports businesses to innovate
and grow
s in the creative Brilliance of our
scientists and universities applies them
to creating the industries of the future
and uses whatever tool the job requires
procurement
r d investment patient finance a
strategic plan for infrastructure and
Supply chains
led by an institution a new industrial
strategy Council that sits outside the
political cycle now
I know this isn't the sort of stuff that
sets Westminster pulse's racing not a
bit of it
but I can tell you this
in every one of our competitors it's the
bread and butter of responsible economic
management
now yesterday
I went on the gov UK website in search
of the government's industrial strategy
this is what I found
it says
reading from it the aim of the
industrial strategy was to boost
productivity by backing businesses to
create good jobs
was
and scratch scratched across the top is
one word I kid you not
archived
archived
doesn't that just tell you everything
the government has archived Britain's
growth
that's why situations like British bolt
keep happening
by the CEO of Johnson Matthey says we're
falling behind in the race for clean
hydrogen
why electric car manufacturers are
leaving Britain in droves
our aversion to proper long-term
industrial strategy is costing us
billions already
but even worse it's costing us the
foundations of a more prosperous future
and Conference so will the status quo on
skills
any serious plan for growth must accept
the need to transform how our country
trains people for work
that's why we're committed to changing
the way government supports businesses
to get the skills that you need
that this conference last year
I announced that Lord blunkett would
lead our Council of skills advisors
and this year I'm pleased to announce
that he's delivered that report and
we're going to deliver on skills
the apprenticeship Levy is not flexible
enough
now don't get me wrong apprenticeships
are a gold standard qualification
their record in tackling the cultural
snobbery associated with vocational
learning is second to none
but alongside them
we also need to fund the training that
works for you
the need for technology short courses
that train coders in weeks
that help younger workers get promoted
the training that supports older workers
to flourish
or retrain of something new
and let you let me tell you from
personal experience
there's nothing wrong with changing your
career in your mid-50s
but the bottom line is this
you need more control over what training
your Levy can buy
with labor that's exactly what you will
get
and will devolve the power and money on
adult skill budgets as well
decisions that drive growth growth in
communities should be made by people
with skin in the game
I profoundly believe that the people and
businesses of Birmingham know what
training the economy of Birmingham needs
and the same is true in Wolverhampton
and wrexham Peterborough and Portsmouth
the next Labor government will spread
economic power to the Grassroots
and our Central Industrial Mission clean
Power by 2030 will help us do it
climate change is the defining social
challenge of our times
there's no question about that I'm sure
it scores highly on the risk register of
every company in this room
but if you take only one thing from
today
let it be this
I don't see climate change as a risk
I see it as an opportunity
the biggest chance we've had in a
generation to make our economy work for
working people
that's what our green Prosperity plan is
all about
a plan to make Britain a green growth
superpower
to invest in Wind solar nuclear hydrogen
green steel and carbon capture
new opportunities for plumbers
electricians Engineers software
designers technicians builders
insulation for 19 million homes
and Great British energy a new National
Champion that will take advantage of the
opportunities in clean British power and
turn them into good secure well-paid
British jobs
you could never say it enough
clean British power is cheaper than
imported fossil fuels nine times cheaper
if we have more of it businesses and
working people will get cheaper bills
the country enjoys independence from
tyrants like Putin
and we give every Community a shot at
the green jobs of the future
clean hydrogen in South Yorkshire
merseyside and the east of England
offshore wind in Scotland T side east of
North Yorkshire
solar power growing rural communities in
the Southeast the southwest and yes here
in the Midlands
it won't be easy we know that
on planning on off gems remit on getting
ahead of demand issues with the grid
we not only see the battles ahead
we'll run towards them
because nothing wreaks of decline more
than the idea Britain no longer knows
how to build things
I won't accept that
and with real partnership we'll win
the same is true on finance
big Ambitions require public investment
and we will provide it
but we know that the real game changer
is private investment
and that this is the perennial challenge
for British productivity
that's why we'll also set up a national
Sovereign wealth fund and use it to
manage risk on the critical Investments
we need to become a green growth
superpower
but also to create spillover
opportunities for businesses and Supply
chains right across the country
in manufacturing and services
that is what an industrial strategy and
partnership must deliver in a nutshell
a new way of managing our economy
a fresh start for Britain
and it's a divide
with the government
last week
you saw the sum total of their offer on
growth
stagnation dressed up in the clothes of
stability
Klein paraded as tough decisions
tough decisions will be challenging
their party on planning on onshore wind
on Industrial strategy
but they don't have it in them don't
understand that to be a careful Steward
of the economy in a volatile world you
need to be proactive
need to intervene to secure stability
and growth
I'll put it simply every business in
this room
has a strategy for growth
a nation needs one too
because the headwinds we face
climate change artificial intelligence
caring for an aging Society
mean that a hands-off approach just
isn't fit for purpose anymore
and I'm not going to give up on growth
that easily
I believe in our country
I believe in our businesses and I
believe in our people
Britain deserves better
a new partnership for prosperity
the path to a green Affair a more
Dynamic country
to higher wages higher skills higher
productivity to Leading the world on the
greatest challenge punished facing our
planet
to give working people a sense of hope
aspiration and possibility once again
thank you conference
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much
we're going to take some questions I'm
going to start with the media so I'm
hoping we've got Alex Forsyth from the
BBC here with us hello thank you Alex
Forsyth BBC News you talk about the need
for businesses to invest in skills and
training in the UK Workforce but that
will take time and you would have heard
from Business Leaders here about
crippling labor shortages now that are
hampering growth so how far would your
pragmatic approach go in terms of
increasing immigration in the short term
and how much is your stance on this
driven by political considerations as
much as economic ones well Alex just let
me take the final part of that question
first because
um I am utterly frustrated
at the short-term fixes what we've had
for the last 12 years is the repetition
of the same argument whether it's on
energy whether it's on skill shortages
which is what are you going to do in the
here and now don't address the midterm
in the long term
and we keep going round and round this
circle the crisis is now sticking
plaster never the medium and the long
term and that is holding us back so I
believe profoundly in the argument I'm
making about skills here I remember back
in 2015 when I first came into politics
I was the shadow immigration Secretary
of glutton for punishment but talking to
many people in this room we had a
discussion about skills and it's not
dissimilar to the discussion we're
having today so if we always see this as
a short-term fix I will be pragmatic of
course I do I don't want to repeat of
what we saw last year with hgv drivers I
get that as I say that's anti-growth and
anti-business but we have to address the
medium and the long term and it's a
feature of the last 12 years that we
haven't got to grips with the medium and
the long term and that will hold us back
and that's why of course we'll be
pragmatic of course we understand that
we need to act now so that we help
business and drive growth but we have to
address and run towards the challenge
that is skills run towards the challenge
that is ensuring we have everybody back
in the workforce because there are
hundreds of thousands of people who
aren't working now who were working just
a few years ago and so this is for me an
economic argument
um not a question of political tactics
thank you Alex I think we have all brief
from the guardian
hello Sakia you alluded in your speech
to the importance that you want to place
on economic stability can you be a bit
more Frank with the public and Business
Leaders in this room about the sorts of
policies that you think you won't be
able to implement as quickly as you
would like if labor wins the next
general election well Aubry I'm not
gonna
draft the next Labor Manifesto here on
stage but what I am saying this and it's
a very important point for me to make to
this audience which is
um we will inherit an economy that's
been damaged by the last 12 weeks in the
last 12 years and we need to
fundamentally accept that as an incoming
government
restoring stability is key there's a
cost to instability and we've been
paying that cost over the last few weeks
and over the last few years that means
restoring faith in our institution it
means clear fiscal rules we've set out
that we'll pay for day-to-day that we
want debt down as a percentage of our
economy
um but you know that stability has to be
our first priority if that means that
there are things which good labor things
I say that which we can't do as quickly
as we would like then that is a
consequence of that security but I will
not give up Bond growth that's why I've
said what I've said about the investment
that we need the approach we need to
skills and getting people back into the
workforce and Innovation but do we need
to restore Faith restore stability Aubry
yes we do do I accept that as an
incoming government it's not good enough
for me to Simply say well they made the
mess we don't have to be responsible
about clearing it up we are going to
have to be responsible about clearing it
up clear fiscal rules do I accept that
that means that there are good labor
things that as an incoming government we
won't be able to do as quickly as we'd
like yes I do accept that I'm not going
to spell it out now but that's the
conversation we want to have over the
coming months as we go into that general
election
um thank you Aubry Lizzy I think from
Bloomberg
thanks to care um the economy is being
significantly held back by this shortage
of workers what makes you think that you
can fix that with the domestic labor
force when governments historically and
everywhere have consistently failed to
do so thank you well
um Lily I'm not going to just give up on
this to Simply say that because we've
not failed to address these issues in
the last 12 years we shouldn't try now
is the wrong approach as far as I'm
concerned if you take just one example
the NHS my wife works in the NHS so I
know pretty well we discuss it a lot
amongst the pressures in the NHS is the
the basic lack of Staff we don't have
enough people in the NHS and again there
are two approaches one to say well let's
have a sticking plaster then deal with
it in the short term the others say no
let's address the medium and the long
term and that's why we've put in place a
plan to train up 15 000 doctors more
nurses more midwives coming into the NHS
because the message we need to send to
the NHS is the Cavalry is coming we
understand the problem and we've been
held back by the fact that we haven't
trained enough doctors coming into the
NHS so
um you know the mere fact that in the
last 12 years this hasn't been gripped
is not a good good enough reason for me
not to grip it the exact there's the
example in skills I've had the same
discussion on skills with people in this
room for seven years
we can't just say well it's impossible
to do anything about it I do think we
can change the way we address skills and
we have to address it and it will be a
feature of an incoming labor government
that we will think strategically and in
the long term that's what I mean by
partnership a government being clear
about what we need to achieve the time
frame in which we will want to achieve
it and how we work in partnership with
business to achieve it but I'm certainly
Lizzy not going to give up on any of
this on the basis that this government's
failed to do it that's why we need the
change that's why we need a general
election
uh Graham from the mirror
please
good morning um Graham has got some
Daily Mirror energy is one of the big
concerns for some if not many people in
this room
um what would labor do to help those
companies and given the wider energy
crisis what would the party do to help
businesses and households that doesn't
mean yet higher government borrowing or
the need for deeper spending cuts again
every question this is good every
question is highlighting this problem of
short-term fixes versus long-time
Solutions now we need we need something
that answer the question how can you pay
your bills this winter we get that
that's why we LED best part of a year
ago now on the idea of
um you know ensuring that we use some of
those oil and gas profits the profits
they didn't expect to make and put it
towards our energy cost but that's not a
longer term or midterm answer we need to
run towards Renewables we need an
independent source of energy of our own
and we need to frankly knock out some of
the obstacles in the way if you take
onshore wind farms this government is
still blocking on Shore wind farms
probably the cheapest form of renewable
energy we could have and if we're going
to go down that road I'll be clear with
you lots of businesses have said to me
it's planning and regulation like that
that's holding us up you know I've had
Frank conversations with CEOs who say we
could build a wind farm in under two
years
but it takes seven years by the time you
add in the planning and the regulation
the role of government is to knock some
of that out of the way and so we need a
longer term solution to this whether
it's wind farms or anything else but
running towards renewable energy there
are so many opportunities for us but we
need to do it running towards that
challenge I'll give you another example
that I find deeply deeply frustrating 19
million homes in this country are
leaking their energy because they're too
drafty so it's costing a fortune to heat
a house which is then losing the heat
because the house is drafting ten years
ago we set about doing something about
that that's all dropped off in the last
few years I said over a year ago we
should have a national mission to
retrofit our houses to make sure they're
better insulated and nothing's been done
about it if we've done something about
it two million houses now would be
better insulated two million families be
paying less bills we've got to start
thinking about the medium and the long
term and working together in a partner
ship to achieve that because otherwise
we'll be doing what we've done for the
last 12 years it's a sticking plaster
sticking plaster sticking plaster never
address the real problem and that is
what leads in the end to stagnation the
single biggest problem in the last 12
years is our problem on growth thank you
very much and I think we've got Dan from
the ft
thank you
um can I ask you to be clear first of
all that you think immigration levels
currently are too high and that your
policies will reduce in a net uh
reduction in Immigration or simply lead
to different sorts of immigration and
secondly can I ask uh after a weekend of
reading about Swiss style trade deals
why a labor brexit deal with the EU
looks like
uh thank you Dan I mean on the question
of numbers
um I always start with what is driving
the numbers when we discuss immigration
and if what's driving the numbers
is our skills failure
or one of the big drivers is skills
failure then I think we need to address
the skills issue rather than just
talking about arbitrary numbers which is
why I've set out the argument I have in
the way I've made my speech this morning
and that does mean if we get this right
that immigration will go down in some of
those areas that are overly reliant on
immigration
but equally I'm not going to hold
businesses back if there's Innovation
Technologies where we do need
um you know Talent from abroad but you
know where we've been over Reliant and
where we've been over Reliant because
we've failed on skills I want to address
that by fixing the skills issue I want
to address the issue we've got with
hundreds of thousands of people out of
the labor market now when they were in
it only a few years ago that as I say
takes us into the question of what are
we doing about the NHS and mental health
which is holding many people back so
that's the way in which I see it on the
Swiss model look I've said
a number of occasions
um that we are not going back
um to the EU and that means not going
back into the single Market or the
Customs Union but we have to make brexit
work the deal this government has got us
is not working well it's holding
business back it's holding growth back
there are things that we need to do to
address it some of them we could start
straight away the protocol in Northern
Ireland needs a pragmatic answer and I
think I've talked to businesses in
Northern Ireland they have pragmatic
approaches to how we could deal with the
protocol in Northern Ireland we need to
reduce trade barriers by being clear
that we want high standards there isn't
a conflict there there's something we
can build on we need to share more when
it comes to Education and Research and
scientific research in particular I
think there's much more we can do in the
security space if you look particularly
at the response to the Ukraine crisis
and the way NATO and the EU have worked
together so I do think that we can have
a better brexit I think that we have to
make brexit work and I think what's
happened so far has been a government
that simply said the words get brexit
done and put in place a deal which I
think most people in this room would say
is not working well for business it's
not working well for exports is not
working well for growth and I want to
fight the next election on growth I want
to fight the next election on the
economy and I want an incoming labor
government to have the economy and
growth of the economy as the absolute
Focus for what we want to deliver on in
a five-year labor government thank you
so much
thank you very much Brian
we've got time for about three questions
from the audience but I think I would
exercise there cheers privileged by one
ahead of that if you get the keys of
dining Street tomorrow what will be top
of your list for driving growth uh our
clean power 2030 which is setting out a
plan for what we want to achieve
um and it the plan and How We Do It Go
together I can't I really need to stress
this to this audience yes an incoming
government sets the goal that is
legitimate in a democracy you win the
right to set the missions we should be
talking to you about what the missions
are before we get there by the way so
that you think they're achievable but
then what we have is a partnership
Arrangement on on the reason I'm using
the partnership example so much now is I
want to build that relationship that
partnership way of working so that if
and when we come into government we can
do it from day one on that first day
hopefully in Downing Street so that
we're saying to you how do we deliver
this together what do you need us to do
as a government what leave us as the
government Paul what does business do in
this there are different models an
incoming government can say We'll suck
it all up to the government nationalize
everything we're not going to do that
Lincoln upcoming government can say
um well we set the mission but the
market knows best so we'll just back off
not going to do that a true partnership
where we work together to achieve the
missions of the next Labor government
okay first question uh
is Emma here Emma just if you see who
you are who your company is and then the
brief question thank you
my question really will allude probably
to the CBI uh theme go for growth and
and
really
what I would like to ask
um if you become a prime minister what
would be the first thing you would like
to change to make this country more
competitive and what would be your
expectation from business to support you
in your objectives
um Emma it's a version of what I've just
said to Brad which is
um setting out our mission for growth
how we're going firstly one we want
growth I think that's really because
I've obviously want better public
services but the two go together so
growth has to be the single Focus have
to be clear about what we mean by growth
and this is what I said in the speech
there are different models of growth
you can say we want to grow and one way
to do it is to grow London and the
southeast very very quickly even more
along to the southeast provides a lot
already and then use that to
redistribute across the rest of the
country I don't want that model of
growth I think one of the things that
held us back is that we're not using all
the places all the talent across the
whole of the country so
um it's a plan for growth and absolutely
clear understanding and we're about what
we mean by growth because I want to see
growth in every place across the whole
of the United Kingdom and then a way of
working with you and others to deliver
on that the way of working is as
important as the ambition because the
ambition will never be realized if we
don't have that way of working and it's
very important that therefore I use
every opportunity I get that Rachel
Reeves does to discuss with you before
we go into government what that growth
plan looks like because we need we'll
have to hit the ground running and it's
why I've said to my shadow cabinet and I
should share this with this audience
that I don't see business engaged
um for my labor party is simply each
member of The Shadow cabinet thinking oh
what are the businesses in my area I
better make sure I've had a cup of tea
with them it's a way of working it's
actually having a discussion about what
we want to achieve and practicing a
partnership so that when we get into
government we're not doing it for the
first time we're continuing discussion
that we've had all the way into it so
Emma that's really important to what I
want to achieve and very important for
me to get across to this audience many
of whom I've spoken to about it about
the way in which an incoming labor
government will work with you and that's
what I mean by being pro-business lots
of people use the word pro-business but
it's about how you see business as a
Force for good and then work with it as
a government harnessed together great
thank you thank you very much is it
Marcus over here
good morning uh thank you for joining us
my name's Marcus Watson and I represent
a company called x-links I'm also an
investor in that company and I was
delighted to hear that Central to uh
your plans is green growth so x-links
aims to help solve decarbonize the UK
economy and our first project is to
harvest solar and wind from Morocco and
pipe it to the UK to provide base load
electricity and we plan to deliver eight
percent of the UK's electricity at base
load level and so my my question is I I
would love to know what you will do
additionally or differently to enable
new entrants to the decarbonization
energy world uh to to enter that market
as speedily as possible and as
effectively as possible but Marcus
um
I think amongst the things that we would
do and this is what we see uh GB energy
is absolutely crucial for
um is using government or public
investment as a catalyst
to spark that Innovation and support
that innovation in the first place as
many people in this room will know one
of the things about starting a new area
starting new business starting new
sector is the risk that that carries
with it and the role of government is to
help with that risk not to provide all
of the money when we talk about public
investment I'm not talking about the
public sector putting all of the money
in and taking all of the risk but it is
something where we can innovate and work
with companies businesses sectors to get
you know to prove sometimes the concept
and support and take away some of the
risks that would otherwise inhibit but
Marcus the other thing I should say
because I've said a lot about
um green growth and our ambition there
but that has to sit alongside the world
what we want to do with our other
brilliant sectors you know life sciences
AI are creative Industries which you
know where we find 750 000 jobs I think
across our economy because we need to
see growth everywhere in all sectors but
it will be that way of working
um and um you know because I want
private investment to come in alongside
what we're going to put in but I know
that we're not going to be able to get
that just by saying we want it or
flicking a switch is about a way of
working thank you Marcus thank you we
get time for one more
um
over there yeah is it David
I think it's me hi it's Stuart Mason
from Mutual value thank you
um for such a Clear Vision this morning
over here
right at the back in the chief it's a
very bright lights here I can't cheap
seats
um thank you for such a clear narrative
this morning a Clear Vision and um uh uh
the setting out your your vision of
partnership question I have is whether
we can trust that given some of its
recent history the part your party's
behind you in this and your way of
working and the trace unions in the
approach that you're taking
uh Stuart thank you for that question
because it gives me the opportunity to
reinforce a very important point which
is the labor party has changed we've
turned the labor party inside out
um and that's particularly significant
when it comes to the way we're working
with business and I think anybody who's
engaged with me or with Rachel Reeves or
any of the Shadow cabinet knows that and
can see the different way of working but
we've also managed and I said it in my
speech to unite the party behind me some
of you will have been at our conference
in Liverpool this year there was a very
different feel to that conference now
you know as labor party members and
activists we would say that we want that
to be the case but I think In fairness
almost everybody who attended that
conference came away with the feeling
that the labor party has changed and you
know it's very difficult for the
opposition to get cut through
and it only happened so it's a bit like
the beam on a lighthouse it only comes
round onto the opposition once every
year so often it came onto us in our
conference and that beam illuminated a
labor party that had changed a labor
party that had the answers to the
challenges that our country is facing
and a late parties that the confidence
to put those ideas into action and
therefore Stuart I say to you loud and
clear this labor party has changed there
is no going back and it is United behind
what we're trying to achieve and you saw
that at our party conference and some of
you will have been there and I think
we'll testify that it felt like a very
very different conference to some of the
conference we've had in recent years
it's the best conference we've had
frankly since 1996. thank you very much
Stuart thank you very much Kia thank you
thank you
thank you uh thanks very much to secure
and to Brian and now I'm going to give
you a quick snap reaction whilst they
Clear the Stage so I've developed these
thoughts as you were speaking let's see
how it goes
um I think that it was really fantastic
to see such a pro-business and pro
partnership message uh from the leader
of the opposition